I am taking 5,000 milligrams of vitamin C divided daily, vitamin E and others like SEAC.
Is this okay or too much antioxidants?
Okay, so, you know, you've been on my Zoom calls for a very long time, taking 5,000 milligrams
of vitamin C divided daily is I do not think that's the right thing to do for somebody who
has cancer and the vitamin E depends on the dosage that you're taking of the vitamin E.
If you're taking a fairly low dose of vitamin E, then it's functioning as an antioxidant
that you shouldn't be taking that.
Either you have to increase the dose or to stop taking it all together.
I do have a blog post on Harnessed Oxidated Stress to Kill Cancer, and we've talked about
it, you know, a lot on the Zoom call about taking vitamin C orally.
So if you're taking 5,000 milligrams at one time, you're probably absorbing about 3,000 milligrams
and you could argue that that's a high enough dosage that it's not functioning as an antioxidant
anymore, it's functioning more as an antioxidant at 3,000 milligrams.
I would probably agree with that, but if you're dividing the dose, let's say you're taking
2500 in the morning and 2500 in the evening, now your absorption of that 2500 is probably
around 1200 because you're really going to absorb about half of what you take orally.
You're probably absorbing about 1250, that's functioning as an antioxidant, now I don't
think you should do that.
So you want to make sure you're taking a single dose at a high enough level of vitamin
C that it's going to function as an oxidative agent to cancer, and that is an antioxidant.
So if you're taking 5,000 milligrams a day of vitamin C, I would take it as single dose,
and the vitamin E, I can't remember the dose that you want to be at for an antioxidant
of stress levels, so go back to my blog post-hardic and oxidative stress to kill cancer.